hey this is the reason interview with
nick gillespie and i'm so excited about
today's show i want to play you this
short clip with my guest
kind of from the middle of the interview
check it out i'm not even going to tell
you who it is i just want you to listen
my concern is that i feel like
socialists are taking over
they're marching through the
institutions they're taking everything
over they've and taken over education it
looks like they've taken over
a lot of the corporations it looks like
they've taken over um
the military and and it's just
continuing i'm so i'm deeply concerned
about um
you know i'm a capitalist at heart and
i'm a lib and i believe in liberty and
capitalism those are my my twin values
and i feel like you know with the
way freedom of speech is today
the movement on on gun control
a lot of the liberties that i've taken
for granted most of my
life i think are under threat so that's
john mackey the co-founder and retiring
ceo of whole foods the grocery store
that forever changed not only how we
shop for food but how we think about
supermarkets
if you are as old as me and i'm pretty
old i
turned 19 i was born in
1963 i just turned
uh 59 years old but if you're as old as
me you remember how dreary food shopping
was
you know most of the time before whole
foods exploded the concept right and
then and the the shopping space the
supermarket space you'd walk down the
produce island there'd be two or three
types of potatoes uh maybe one kind of
eggplant you know the dark black blue
purple eggplant if you were lucky it's
kind of an ethnic food you know right
what you know what's that doing a green
pepper a sad little jalapeno or
something you know there was nothing
like the overflowing bounty that
you know you see everywhere today even
in big cities i can tell you you know
you had to roam around all over town to
find oddball spices that are everywhere
now that you can buy at 7-eleven or gas
stations for god's sake
you know since it got going in 1978
whole foods has forced
every
kroger safeway shoprite foodtown heb
pantry which is a great chain based in
texas
but and even walmart super centers to up
their games when it came to the variety
of what they sell and how they sell it
and what prices and all of that kind of
stuff so john
is retiring
at the end of the month he was born in
1953's in his late 60s
and his retirement is a bittersweet
moment not just for him but for whole
foods uh and
and all of its customers i feel that way
over the course of his career john
developed and evangelized for what he
calls conscious capitalism or businesses
that seek to create and i'm reading from
its credo there's a website that's also
in the show page links but
conscious capitalism uh works to create
businesses that seek to create financial
intellectual social cultural emotional
spiritual physical and ecological wealth
for all of their stakeholders and you
might be thinking oh you know what is
this hippie stuff going on what's this
hippie crap about stakeholders and
spiritual wealth no it's capital wealth
it's it's stock returns right
but john is one of the hardest core if
not the hardest core capitalists that
i've ever met but he's also an
incredibly spiritual and thoughtful guy
who wants to help all of us live better
more interesting lives i've known him
for it's got to be 20 years now and i've
talked with him many times over the
years for a reason uh there will be
links in the homepage at reason.com
podcast
uh you know for this episode and um you
know to our past interviews and also to
his epic 2005 debate with nobel laureate
milton friedman one of his heroes and
former cypress semiconductor ceo t.j
rogers about rethinking the social
responsibility of business
for a really long time it was always one
of the highest traffic pages on our our
website for years
after uh we posted it in 2005
and for good reason because he is
speaking to where we are in a world that
is past the industrial revolution that
has passed subsistence farming and that
is rich enough so that we can start
bumping our snouts further and further
up abraham maslow's hierarchy of needs
and start figuring out how we can
flourish rather than just subsist
i caught up with john at freedom fest
the annual gathering in las vegas uh he
was coming off the stage he had just
participated in a debate about bitcoin
and crypto uh short version uh he's not
against them in principle but he thinks
there's a lot of scams going on in the
current market but
mostly what we talked about was his time
at whole foods and what it was like
saying goodbye to the company that he
had created into this international
behemoth that has
changed the way that we think about how
we do business
how his company did an exceptional job
of staying open and serving people
during covet how he thought the
government responded to things both by
regulating businesses in all sorts of
ways he also is skeptical of the
vaccines that have come out certainly of
the mandates we disagree a little bit
about that for sure
um but we talk about all of that and
more including that creeping socialism
that he's worried about that was in the
clip that i played just a couple seconds
ago a couple minutes ago and we of
course talked about what he's going to
be doing now that he's retiring and the
good news on that front is that
john told me that he's been muzzled or
he's felt muzzled by his position as ceo
of whole foods that in that role you
know he's got a fiduciary responsibility
and he can't really speak his mind on a
wide variety of issues
you know because he's got to take care
of shareholders stockholders
stakeholders you name it but it's and he
told me at freedom fest that he's going
to be spending part of his time
post whole foods working on some health
and wellness startups we talk a little
bit about that but um he's going to be
spending a lot of his time
talking about what he sees as a society
that is trying to control and regulate
the life out of us all you know from
there's right-wing versions of that in
left-wing versions and he is going to be
speaking out unmuzzled against that so
without further ado here is
the reason interview with john mackey
let me ask you this you know the
the covid era has been like a clarifying
moment right um and one of the things
that i got to tell you and i feel like
i'm almost special pleading but i live a
couple blocks
from the houston street whole foods in
manhattan
and you know when the lockdown was
happening in manhattan i went to whole
foods to get a bunch of stuff and it was
amazing like the shells were clearing
out immediately this was in march of
2020
but you know the next day people were
working there the shelves were filling
up as quickly as they could
talk about whole foods response and like
how did whole foods and some other
grocery store chains did this too i mean
a lot of them we were told you know
there was going to be massive disruption
that all sorts of things how did you
keep it together
to keep
your your workers healthy and showing up
and food on the shelves well there was
massive disruptions and
it was very difficult very difficult
time
the lockdowns i believe history will
show that that was probably the
stupidest thing
that
the government
would have done will have done in the
21st century unless they get into a
nuclear war it was idiotic and even that
will be able to shop freely right well i
mean
the so-called vaccinations didn't really
prevent covid i mean which is what you
expect a vaccination to do
and uh there have been lots of side
effects for people and my wife is a long
hauler now from the booster
of all things so in the places of
lockdown like new zealand and australia
now they're
now they have epidemic uh infection
rates so you're so you're not sold on
the
mrna vaccines no i mean it was
experimental and they didn't they didn't
deliver as were promised i thought we
were getting you know when i get a polio
vaccination i expect i'm never going to
get polio not that in six months i've
got to get a polio booster do you and
even if i got it
i got both vaccinations and i still got
coveted like almost everybody i know i
still got covey but and you don't
believe that you got a lesser version of
it than you might have had otherwise
that the the efficacy of the vaccines is
not in preventing the disease but
lessening the effects i mean i have lots
of friends that didn't get vaccinations
and they didn't get seriously ill as
well it seemed to be
statistically now it seems to be a
disease
i mean you know eighty percent of the
deaths in the united states were where
the people that are obese right and most
of them are you know over 70 years of
age so it was selective in its killing
it's just the media didn't really report
on it and anybody that gave a counter
narrative was sort of canceled out or
they weren't allowed to so talk about
that
how did whole foods respond yeah so it
was very difficult for us we were an
essential business so we were able to be
open for business it was very hard on
the morale of the company our team
members were scared
right they're being exposed probably to
covid and they didn't bat in in the
early days we didn't know what to expect
was that a death sentence it was amazing
too that for all the discussion of okay
essential workers or front front line
workers there was not a lot of empathy
for grocery workers
in a way i'm not sure what you mean by
empathy uh what i mean is that there was
a lot of discussion of teachers there
were a lot of discussions of people who
worked in hospitals and what they were
putting up with but
people who were in well
the teacher the teachers
they they started they were all online
yeah no that what i'm saying is it's
amazing to me that you know the people
who showed up every day were the people
who were working in in markets
supermarkets and and drug stores well we
paid we raised the pay of everybody and
uh
but still it was very hard because
people were scared they didn't know what
to expect um there were no vaccinations
available even if they didn't work at
least they you know the placebo effect
at least for many people
uh they didn't have that and people were
scared anytime anybody came down with
kovid that you know they were 14 day
quarantine anybody that they were
um any of our team members they might
have been around we're also quarantined
so we had a lot of trouble keeping our
keeping the staff going because a lot of
times some stores would be i remember
going into one of our our
the downtown austin store where i
officed and shopped one time in the we
had no we had no cashiers available
everybody was forced to go to
self-checkout fortunately we had
self-checkout
because there were no everybody was
quarantined
so it was very difficult and then also
the social distancing our our
whole foods culture is very um
touchy-feely a huggy culture and
everybody's social distancing it's like
the guy next you might have the plague
and so nobody's touching people aren't
they're isolating so you have like
incredibly high traffic stores too right
i mean it's yes yes so but you know i
what happened of course is that amazon
helped us scale up our delivery quicker
and then we would have been able to do
on our own and at our peak 28 of our
sales were coming from delivery
so um is that you know on a certain
level and what was it before that what
was
two or three percent so it's a massive
increase but it still seems kind of low
right because it seemed like everybody
was getting everything delivered well
most people weren't getting delivered
they also were pickup and
but then there was you know people just
coming in lining up but the difference
is is they would have a list and they
would race through the store to get the
hell out of there because they were so
scared they had to get food
but they didn't you know no sampling's
going on our prepared foods business
crashed we in fact they wouldn't let us
our salad bars our hot bars anything
back in the day remember we before we
realized that covid was an airborne
disease we had contaminated people
worried that you know you could pick it
up off of
somebody's surface infections and that
that proved not to be true but the fear
was there so all of our prepared food
sales dropped down 80 80 percent
hot bars salad bars all that
self-service stuff was eliminated what
is the what's the morale like now
because it seems like you know we people
know kind of what we're dealing with
it's a great question
you know i am retiring from whole foods
in just six weeks now oh wow and i leave
september first 44 years
and uh
but i've been on a grand tour to say
goodbye went to all 10 of our regions
been in over 100 stores in the last
couple of months saying goodbye
morale is very high it's very high right
now very high is that because you're
leaving i think that might be the case
they sure were cheering a lot for me so
on the way out not when they saw you but
i i think yeah why is that though that's
i mean that's great to hear i think
because
it's things are normalized meaning
people are not having to wear a mask
they are they're able to hug and touch
again they've they've
team meetings have come back
life is normalizing again for most
people and so they they suffered through
a couple of years of of you know not
really having any
connection with their friends right not
going out to a bar and having a beer
after work and and hanging out now
they've gotten through it and they've
survived i think it's kind of like the
joy of surviving
like a near-death experience life is
precious and you realize that you still
got it um how did you know the merger
with amazon
is interest i mean like ultimately it
turned out to be pretty opportune for
certainly for your customers
how did you know how did that work or
did it did it accelerate changes in the
way whole foods operates or the way
amazon operates
the good thing is amazon did not try to
really change whole foods as culture it
didn't try to make us into amazon and
cologne
they didn't understand our culture so
that was uh sometimes we had difficult
communication challenges there
but they were respectful of the culture
they helped us in technology i mean i
mean it's taken a while but we have our
first couple of
just walk out stores
up and running now but a lot of people
are are scared of that technology
they've also got grocery carts that can
scan as you go in the grocery cart
and we're now introducing those into our
stores and of course they accelerated
our delivery they were able to scale up
quicker than we could have done so
they've helped us with technology how
about uh you know not necessarily amazon
but you know one of the things that is
incredible about whole foods and i
always used to think about this you know
25 years ago of how whole foods is the
embodiment of global free trade and you
know because so much of your stuff is
coming from its source from all over the
world
is that coming back to normal or how
stressed was that supply chains you what
you what you read about and what you've
probably written about is covid has
messed up
supply chains around the world i mean so
much stuff's manufacturing china
those relationships have been have been
definitely disrupted
energy is a problem mainly
like
all types of you know we we're still
opening 20 to 30 stores a year and we've
had to delay store after store of the
store we just can't get buildings we
can't get the stuff we need
different things go scarce so
supply chains will normalize again
because that's the way capitalism works
but right now
um that's driving up the cost of new
construction tremendously there have
been tight labor as you know labor's
been tight we're there's not a store in
our company that we're not down several
people
have you did you find the uh and i i'm
not sure how this would have worked in a
whole foods context but the expansion of
federal unemployment benefits in most
states
increased the amount they gave and
extend extended the version did that
have an impact on your workers
it had a
it had an impact on our ability to hire
a lot of people were making as much
money or more money not working at all
right and so guess what they chose not
to work
and it's been they've been reluctant to
come back to work it's sort of um they
got used to it do you think that is also
i mean fitting into a kind of
generational shift you're you're a baby
boomer i'm a baby boomer and i don't you
know the hell there's a lot that's wrong
with the baby boom but things are
different now they are different i've
i've become
i remember i constantly was telling my
father as a dad you just don't
understand our generation
and i feel like i've become my father i
don't understand the younger generation
they they don't seem to want to work and
um do you think that i couldn't i
couldn't wait to work work for me i
started working as soon as i was able to
because that's how i could get money to
spend things do you think it's they
don't want to work because they don't
have to whether it's their parents or
government kind of federal yes i don't
know
um
maybe they don't only want to work if it
works really purposeful and aligned well
i would think at whole foods that that's
kind of a place where it's a purposeful
workplace more than
i mean my first 10 years of jobs weren't
it wasn't because i loved the work right
i needed the money
well um
that maybe so we may be having fewer
problems than starbucks is having i
don't know for sure yeah but i know that
we're
we're really straining
to get people higher particularly in the
cities like
new york the big ones new york
la
chicago san francisco
seattle can i can i ask you is that
because i want to talk about conscious
capitalism which is you know one of the
things that you've been pushing that
we've reached a different stage of
societal development where
post-industrial revolution
work should be more meaningful our
activity is more symbolic and imbued
with
deep commitments or reflections of our
deep commitments is that
part of the you know what some people
call the great resignation or whatever
that younger people aren't as quick to
work because they want meaningful work
it may be uh
but you can't expect to start with
meaningful work i mean
you're gonna have to earn it i'm hoping
with meaningful yes exactly well i think
you're doing meaningful work ever since
you joined reason right you're aligned
with your values with that unless you
want to go on the record saying no no no
i mean but it takes a while to get there
and i enjoyed my work
you had to pay a price to get where you
are yeah i some of the younger
generation doesn't seem to be willing to
pay that price
and i don't know why i don't know
whether it's their parents or
i mean well you're a student of
schumpeter yeah and i mean are we in
that stage of capitalism where
it kind of starts to eat itself because
we've forgotten that
wealth is not a given wealth is let me
tell you something so
yes that may be true but let me make a
counter narrative which is as i just
done this tour and i've been in a
hundred whole foods market stores in the
last two or three months
and
because it's my last time i was touring
they knew the last time i was going to
be in their store as a ceo it's
incredibly touching it is
a lot of people come up and tell me
their stories
they wanted to know how much they loved
whole foods and they wanted me to tell
them the story and of course whole foods
has a massive amount of first generation
immigrants working in our stores
and
so many of them came up and they were
crying and they took like this one woman
in one of our dc stores she came up said
you need to hear my story
i joined this company 23 years ago right
after i immigrated to the united states
i had three very small children i went
to work here i've been promoted six
times
my third child just graduated from
college
i own a house
and i own a rental property too
and she was crying when she was telling
me all this i owe whole foods everything
the american dream is still alive
and immigrants are still flocking over
here and they can move up and they're
her she's so proud of her children they
went through college she put them
through i
and she she feels like whole foods gave
her that opportunity hey before we
continue the recent interview with nick
gillespie i want to introduce you to
today's sponsor
it is a company called
everydaydose.com if you're like most
people like i used to be you start your
day with a cup of coffee but you know
your favorite habit is probably causing
some serious negative side effects for
your health your energy and your mood
so i want you to think about starting
your morning the way i do with a great
beverage called everyday dose it is
great tasting affordable and it makes my
morning something
that i look forward to
but before i sell you on the particulars
of everyday dose i want to give you
facts that will make you pour your
coffee down the drain before you even
sip it just throw it out already okay
because normal coffee
has a bunch of problems with it first
off it's highly acidic which is why it
gives your stomach aches sometimes it
weakens the lining of digestive systems
and it messes with your microbiome over
time and that can lead to uncomfortable
or embarrassing gut issues in the short
term but much more serious conditions
over the long haul normal coffee
increases stress hormones in the body
and it causes adrenal fatigue over time
that's why people get caffeine jitters
why they have trouble sleeping at night
they wake up tired they get brain fog in
the middle of the day coffee can even
cause weight gain
drinking lots of traditional coffee also
makes you anxious or irritable you know
this right
because it triggers your body's fight or
flight response so that's the case
against coffee the case for everyday
dose
it combines adaptogenic mushrooms
neotropics and collagen with organic low
acidity cold brew coffee extract that
actually will increase your energy heal
your gut and boost your mood
and like i said i've been i've been
drinking this stuff every morning for
over a year the best part of it it
tastes like coffee so i still get that
morning ritual i love making coffee and
letting it cool and adding cream or
whatever i want in it oat milk you
whatever
but it's a great ritual and then it also
boosts my energy helps my focus
strengthens immunity enhances my mood
improves my quality of sleep restores my
gut health what makes everyday dose
really unique is that it's made from
real usda organic mushrooms these are a
hundred percent fruiting body double
extracted for increased bioavailability
which is a really fancy way of saying
that you absorb everything easily your
body absorbs everything easily that's in
the mushrooms there's no fillers in this
stuff it's the only mushroom coffee on
the market that includes collagen and
l-theanine which really help it be
better
and because it's got low acidity cold
brew coffee extract in it at a small
dose it gives you the optimal amount of
caffeine just 39 milligrams per serving
without upsetting your stomach and i
think i mentioned this it tastes just
like a delicious cup of light cold brew
coffee doesn't taste like mushrooms you
would have no idea that mushrooms are
involved in this it is like coffee
except it's better than coffee
so try everyday dose a delicious better
for you coffee without the jitters
without the crash or digestive issues of
traditional coffee you can try it
absolutely risk-free with a 60-day
money-back guarantee
i don't think you're going to want the
money back i think you're going to want
more everyday dose go to
everydaydose.com
all one word everydaydose.com
today
and get some everyday dose you're going
to love it and now
back to the recent interview with nicole
espy do you feel like and it's not like
you know you know you
when life gives you lemons you make
lemonade or something but like in terms
of conscious capitalism and the idea of
you know
talking about capitalism in a way where
it is you know it is about
self-actualization both on the
individual and at the community level
is this an opportunity uh you know what
happened during covet and
you know the pause in economic activity
is this
you know can you
you know can you use that to your
advantage in order to sell a vision of a
kind of post-industrial capitalism yeah
nick
what worries me right now is that i mean
conscious capitalism is a management
philosophy it's a way you should manage
your business you should figure out what
the higher purpose of your business is
um and that's always going to be in
value creation for other people yeah
it's about whatever it is you're
creating some value for other people or
you wouldn't have a business in the
first place
whole foods higher purpose is to nourish
people in the planet
so um
secondly it's about the stakeholders
that they all matter and they're
interdependent
um and then it's about creating you know
leadership that's that's more awake more
conscious and then cultures that where
people flourish that's the four pillars
of conscious capitalism but i'm very
concerned that
people are uh
that it's being co-opted
that uh
it's it's a management philosophy it's
not a governance system so
esg and i'm oftentimes
being having to defend conscious
capitalism which is being conflated with
esg thinking which is basically a
political philosophy that's trying to
force corporations to adhere to their
particular political philosophies and
taking away power from the shareholders
that's really what it's about uh we're
going to make those corporations and
we're going to put diversity on the
board and we're going to have the the
team members need the employees need to
be represented and the the um but and
the outcomes have to be a certain way
right it's not simply that they're on
the board or they're represented but it
ends up looking this way and so that's
not what cautious capitalism conscious
capitalism is a philosophy a way to
think about your business that is just a
little bit more enlightened a little
more um and i think it's going to be a
more successful way to manage your
business as well it's not about
distorting the governance system to to
to take away the power from the
investors that will screw up capitalism
and maybe i think that's the intention
all along i do um
uh you know do you think uh kind of the
experience with covid
and an economy that has been you know
extremely volatile for almost all of the
21st century you know the leftist
marxist will say this is the end game of
capitalism yeah which they've been
saying
of course but then again you know
libertarians have been saying you know
inflation's coming you know and it it
finally arrives but do you think
the the experience with covid
after the financial crisis after you
know all sorts of uh you know issues is
that going to speed up risk-taking and
innovation or is it going to make people
kind of more fearful both in terms of
starting companies or the way that they
try out new things it's a good question
um
i don't know really the answer to it um
i see difference i see different
statistics that show in some ways we're
more innovative than we've ever been
and others that say that innovation is
slowing down to crawl due to regulations
i guess what what's different it's a lot
easier to get capital now
if you're if you're an entrepreneur it's
so much easier to get capital it was
when i was starting out they didn't even
have venture capitalists really when i
was starting out that was a new thing
coming up in in silicon valley uh
money's easier
but there are other problems labor is
more difficult
the type of regulations that make and so
many people just sell out now because to
go public with
sarbanes-oxley the burden of
the financial burden on small companies
makes it difficult to go to go public
frankly so a lot don't they just sell
out
or now they get the what's the
what's the new form they do
um where you get uh
what is it a spa spec spec stat spec i
forget what it's called uh but it's a
company companies that basically are
already public they don't own anything
but they're already public so they will
acquire a business wanting to go public
and then that's how the company goes
public so that's a way to get
and that's just kind of specialized
vehicle of something or another right
yeah and it's it's like a dead weight
loss or it i mean it's a way around
regulation so
yes exactly so
the interesting thing about capitalism
is
um
it's as as long as it can innovate it
will and if you it's a little bit like
it's like a river flowing if you throw a
rock in there
it it the water moves around the rock
and it just keeps flowing if you throw
enough rocks in it you can dam it up
even then it might break the dam down or
it still might route around it when you
get a flood but using that metaphor
there are a lot of rocks in the water
but innovation's still happening but
it's maybe not as so i think it's maybe
a little more difficult regulatory wise
today than it was
real estate is so much harder to open
for example
it's so much harder to get permitting
in places like la san francisco to just
get permission from the government to
actually build anything it used to be
they'd make you jump through a few
hurdles but the overall thing was sure
yeah do your business now
there's it's all politicized nick if if
if you're not unionized maybe you don't
get the permit
and you they they can always stop you by
putting in
or
calling for study after study after
study after study how's the traffic
study what's this going to do to
employment what's this going to do to
housing i mean it's endless so when when
they for political reasons
governments and locally now are really
making it more difficult for business a
lot of small business people can't deal
with it do you feel in the broad
libertarian movement do you feel like
libertarian ideas and sensibilities are
they ascending are they declining are
they is it kind of always a steady state
of it going well someplace no i think i
remember reading an article by you about
this very question and kind of do that i
think i write it almost on a monthly
basis well it's because um
there are so many ways where we're freer
than we used to be like when we were you
and i were children for example and then
there are other ways where we're less
free right so
um so on balance on balance
on balance
here's the thing it's kind of like you
know they say that um when somebody
praises you or somebody puts you down
it takes 10 10 compliments to make up
for it i think every regulation that
gets in our way it takes about 10
other regulations that are that are you
know not there right that are removed to
make us feel like we're making progress
i think overall we're making still
making progress
but in terms of total numbers um
but the ones that they keep taking the
ones they take away from us are painful
and
it's so
it's an interesting question and i i
uh
i think financially we're a lot more
regulated than we used to be here's the
thing it's tricky because
i mean most regulations come in after
there's some kind of market failure or
some usually not a market failure bad
actors right and so then they punish
everybody in the sector to stop i mean
sarbanes actually came in after the tech
bubble exactly you know and then
dodd-frank came in after the financial
exactly right and regulations don't like
rocks have been thrown in the river they
don't tend to get taken away right that
they did back in the big
regulatory days of like when reagan was
in there and that continued for a while
thatcher did a lot
maybe we'll have to have another wave of
deregulation that may need to occur
as the economy begins to calcify how do
you feel about the you know i mean you
you're you have to deal with politics
even though like your life's work is in
markets and like building value and
you're trying to like pay off or keep
politics out of it um you were critical
of trump but you were also not
hysterical about him you were you know
he was not as bad as the alternative
that's exactly right so you know it's
interesting nick you're gonna like this
because in six weeks i will retire from
whole foods and i have muzzled myself
for the last ever since 2009 i wrote
that wall street journal op-ed that
created this bad huge controversy
about obamacare and my board and if i
may just to recap it about how your the
plan that you had in place was better
than what was going to come in but it
would you like life was being meditated
i just thought we needed to innovate in
healthcare and not one size fits all
right which is what obamacare is really
about and we have the same number or
slightly higher on uninsured people
exactly yeah so
but that created a huge controversy and
my board basically shut me down and said
i they it's like a father
they started attacking the child
and i was
intimidated enough to shut up yeah but
um
you know i hear the story you know
bernie marcus was one of the founders of
home depot
and uh he's he's pretty conservative
libertarian guy he started the job
creators network
and so bernie's pretty outspoken and i
and i read an article one time that
people are constantly going after home
depot to get them to shut up bernie
marcus and home depot has to say bernie
retired over 20 years ago we can't shut
him up you got to take it to bernie well
i was telling my leadership team pretty
soon
you're going to be hearing about crazy
john
who's no longer muzzled and you're going
to have to say we can't stop john from
talking any longer what are they give us
a preview
well i got six weeks okay well you know
what we can hold this until somebody we
could embargo it i can talk more about
politics yeah
[Music]
and in six weeks than i can today what
is just broadly what is your concern
is it that everything is more
politicized in terms of my concern is
that i feel like
socialists are taking over
they're marching through the
institutions they're taking everything
over they and taken over education it
looks like they've taken over
a lot of the corporations it looks like
they've taken over um
the military and and it's just
continuing yeah so i'm deeply concerned
about um
you know i'm a capitalist at heart and
i'm a lib i believe in liberty and
capitalism those are my my twin values
and i feel like you know with the
way freedom of speech is today uh the
movement on on gun control
a lot of the liberties that i've taken
for granted most of my
life i think are under threat yeah
packing a court maybe back in the
supreme court because they uh
vote they're voting down things that uh
how does how does it feel to be in texas
i mean you're in austin so that's
one of the coolest cities in america but
it's also it's in a state that is
increasingly conservative
um does that
you know or do you have concerns about
texas as a place to live for freedom
i don't i like living in texas texans
are friendly i don't pay any
state income taxes
um
you know
abortion laws are going to be
democratized now and people are all in
panic but that's because democracy
hasn't yet gone to work yet so if texas
has too narrow uh uh you know if it's
only five weeks or whatever well
there'll be candidates that run on you
know first try next trimester and
and
democracy will change the way the
abortion laws are and they'll be more
reflective of the overall state values
so
i'm just going to be very interesting to
see how that particular one plays out
and people can will go to different
states or it'll be interesting to see
how it plays out i've been reading the
recent articles on that and uh
i don't agree with
a lot of what i've read in reason about
on the abortion issue which is
being restrictive or
the reason is uh seems to be pretty pro
uh roe versus wade and i always thought
that was bad constitutional law
and you know
yeah i i will cop to being one of the
people who i i tend to think of abortion
as a fundamental right so that
and you know roe versus wade gave a
place where the state did have an
interest after i believe it's a
fundamental right
up to a point right right yeah exactly i
mean would you say it was a fundamental
right up to the day before birth no i
mean you know it's actually in the in
the common law row and then planned
parenthood it's like up to
you know the second trimester or
viability or whatever so this the polls
i show seems to say that right now roe
versus ray wade was within any time
before birth right
so
polls show that about 90 percent of the
population uh opposes that right yep to
birth right right but then about a huge
percentage
are in favor of abortion
in the first trimester right yeah for
the first 15 weeks where i stand on it
is kind of women's right to choose until
we have a viable fetus that can live
right then at some point it becomes
murder right but it's not in the first
trimester because that's not a viable
one of the things i've been showing
since roe v wade
only about 20 percent 19 20 percent of
americans are against abortion under all
circumstances it's been remarkably
constant
and what you know it'll be interesting
as you were saying to see some states
are going to become more extreme in one
direction than in the other the point is
this is the perfect example of something
that
democracy should decide
not
not the supreme court they acted as
legislators i think they were they were
i don't feel but if it's a fundamental
right up to a certain point like it
should be a fundamental right everywhere
perhaps but that's not what's happening
here there's a couple of two old men
talking about abortion who's never had
who's never going to be pregnant
yeah well you know i have some hope for
technological innovation what it what so
what are you going to be doing when you
retire obviously you're going to be
you're going to be embarrassing your the
corporation you spent 44 years building
by being very political but what what
kinds of activities are you going to be
doing and it is your conscious capital
group what kind of activity so three
three things um
first
i'm working on another book um this will
be the whole story the story of whole
foods
it's going to be my most important book
it is going to be narrative not didactic
it's going to be entertaining and funny
because there's so many great stuff this
is the full memoir full memoir
part about me
mostly about whole foods and
there's so many stories that are not
known even within our own company
because you know
they were suppressed like oh because you
don't want business insider getting into
your business all the time so that
stuff's going to come out it's going to
be entertaining
um
secondly i'm i'm going to do a lot more
backpacking i've got a trip planned uh a
hiking trip planned in europe starting
in austria 488 miles i start august 18th
come back like october 3rd
thirdly i'm co-founding another business
with some friends it's going to be
it's called love life
with an exclamation mark and it's it's
it's not ready for prime time yet but
it's going to be
kind of a combination of healthy
restaurants
wellness center
gym spa
and lifestyle medicine so hope to do
we're going to create a whole chain of
those let me uh as we uh
end this but
give the short version you know one of
the things you uh been influential on
through whole foods but also through
your writing is a vegan diet
and you were way ahead of the curve
being anti-kind of seed oil and things
like that
you know
tell me how you're vindicated by
everything around us well i'm very
passionate about this and this is my my
new business is going to be doing this
directly
nick i'm very i'm very discouraged i
mean 74 of adult americans are
overweight and 42 and a half percent are
obese
and those trend lines got the average
adult american gained 27 pounds during
covet because people were just locked in
and so it's like a reverse venezuela
yeah exactly exactly reverse venezuela
uh that's funny i like that um
eighty percent of what we spend on
health care dollars in america are
dietary lifestyle diseases doctor we
know how to reverse heart we know how to
prevent and reverse heart disease and
yet what do doctors do they they don't
tell them they don't know
they they give them a stint and then
they put them on cholesterol medicine
statins
try to give them blood pressure medicine
to keep their blood pressure down
they're just giving them drugs they're
not curing anything
and yet we know how to cure it we know
how to cure type 2 diabetes we know how
to cure obesity and we're not doing it
and
you could argue there's not any money in
it
it's a lot more money
a lot more money made selling drugs to
people who actually don't really but i
guess you're going to be trying to make
money by offering an alternative yes but
it's it's
it's it's difficult challenge to get
people to change the way they eat and
live so
time will tell that we can make money
doing it or not but
i've made a fair chunk of money in my
life more than i need
and
investing it in this new enterprise
i feel i could not i couldn't go to my
grave not doing that i'm not the kind of
man who can just go lie on a beach and
uh
enjoy myself all the time i'd like to do
that for vacations but i'm i'm very
purposeful i need to be doing something
to
i'm very purpose driven well you know
thank you for talking it's good to catch
up with you and also i mean thank you
for whole foods i remember the first
time i got to introduce you at a reason
event i
talked about how you know whole foods to
me is a cathedral of commerce and it you
know you revolutionize not just the
stores you built but the way
food is thought about and is delivered
and it's like it's a more interesting
world because of the way you lined your
produce shelves and everything else so
thank you i do think whole foods has had
a positive effect i hope love life will
have even a bigger effect over time
and hey nick the best thing is i get to
be more activists as a libertarian and
that's been that's been suppressed and i
am going to be more activists you're
going to see me a lot more visible well
thank you john mackey thanks nick this
has been the reason interview with nick
gillespie if you liked what you heard
and i hope you did
please go right now to apple google
spotify stitcher soundcloud wherever you
get your podcast and subscribe
or do this make it easy on yourself and
just go to reason.com podcast and sign
up there and not just for the recent
interview but for our other three
podcasts they include the reason
roundtable a weekly podcast that drops
every monday afternoon with me catherine
mangaward peter suterman and matt welch
hashing out the biggest issues of the
day great way to start the week then
there is the soho forum debates which is
a recording of a live monthly oxford
style debate that reason sponsors in new
york city every month over issues of
particular interest to libertarians and
then finally there's the reason rundown
which is a relatively new weekly podcast
that drops every friday
during which peter suderman talks to a
single reason journalist about a single
big story that's really in the news it
is a great way to end the week please go
to reason.com podcasts and sign up for
all of our shows thanks for listening
[Music]